JUST HURT MY WHOLE SOUL, MY
WHOLE BODY.
>> A DON LEMON TONIGHT
EXCLUSIVE, "INSIDE THE JURY
ROOM."
IT WAS KIND OF TOUGH TO GET YOU
GUYS TO DO THIS.
YOU WERE CONCERNED ABOUT YOUR
SAFETY AND YOUR PRIVACY AND I
UNDERSTAND WHY.
BUT WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO
GET OUT OF THIS?
WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO GET
OUT OF IT?
>> I WANT PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS WAS NO EASY TASK FOR
US.
IT WAS -- I FELT LIKE IT WAS MY
CIVIC DUTY TO STEP FORWARD AND
REPRESENT.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS ABOUT THE
VERDICT AND ABOUT THE WHOLE
PROCESS, BUT IT WASN'T AN EASY
TASK.
WE TOOK THIS VERY SERIOUSLY.
>> I JUST WANTED TO ADD PEOPLE
ARE SEEING STUFF OUT THERE.
I WANT TO SAY THAT'S NOT TRUE.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THERE WAS
PRESSURE TO CONVINCE, AND THAT'S
NOT TRUE.
WE WENT THROUGH EVIDENCE AND
EVERYTHING BEFORE WE MAKE A
DECISION.
>> I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
MISCONSES OUT THERE ABOUT, YEAH,
HOW COULD WE HAVE NOT KNOWN WHAT
WAS HAPPENING OUTSIDE THE
DELIBERATION ROOM AND COURTROOM
BECAUSE A LOT OF STUFF WAS
HAPPENING WHILE WE WERE IN
COURT.
AND WE DIDN'T.
I THINK PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THAT
DUE DILIGENCE WAS DONE AND TAKEN
VERY SERIOUSLY.
>> EVERYBODY TOOK THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
EACH DAY WE CAME IN, WE ALL WERE
FOCUSED AND LOCKED IN AND DURING
THE DELIBERATION WE WERE VERY
ATTENTIVE AND KIND OF ALL ON THE
SAME PAGE IN TERMS OF THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO DO.
>> SO LET'S GO BACK.
LET'S GO TO THE JURY ROOM AND
DLI
DELIBERATIONS.
YOU HAVE COPIOUS NOTES.
>> YEAH, SO HERE ARE MY NOTES.
>> WOW.
>> THESE ARE MY NOTES FROM THE
TRIAL.
IT'S FOUR OF THE BIG AND THEN
THIS WHOLE SMALL ONE, TOO.
SO THE FIRST THING WE DID WAS,
ONE, WE TOOK OFF OUR MASKS AND
THEN WE EXCHANGED NAMES.
WELL, WE MADE SURE EVERYONE WAS
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT, RIGHT.
SO MAYBE SURE EVERYONE WAS
COMFORTABLE ABOUT TAKING ABOUT
THEIR MASK AND MADE SURE
EVERYONE WAS COMFORTABLE SHARING
NAMES.
>> I THINK SOME OF US FELT EAGER
BECAUSE WE'D BEEN HOLDING THIS
IN FOR 3 1/2 WEEKS.
SO IT WAS SOMETHING WE WOULD BE
FINALLY ABLE TO GET OUR THOUGHTS
OUT.
>> SO HOW DID YOU APPROACH IT?
DID YOU VOTE RIGHT AWAY?
>> YES.
>> TELL ME ABOUT THAT.
>> WE VOTED RIGHT AWAY TO GET A
STANCE WHERE WE WERE ALL THAT,
AND OF COURSE WE WEREN'T ALL
TOGETHER, SO WE KNEW WE HAD TO
TAKE EACH STEP LITTLE BY LITTLE.
AND WE VOTED MANY TIMES
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE PROCESS.
>> SO THE FIRST VOTE YOU TOOK
WAS IT OR ANY OF THEM, WERE THEY
ANONYMOUS?
DID YOU DO IT BY NOTE.
>> IT WAS ALL ANONYMOUS.
WE JUST FILLED OUT A PIECE OF
PAPER.
>> YOU HAD NO IDEA.
SO YOU HAD NO IDEA.
SO WHAT WAS THAT FIRST VOTE?
>> THEN I KEPT TRACK.
SO THEN WHEN WE VOTED I WASN'T
T
THE FOREPERSON, BUT I KEPT
TRACK.
AND THE FIRST ONE WE AGREED TO
DISCUSS WAS THE MANSLAUGHTER
CHARGE.
>> THAT WAS THE FIRST VOTE YOU
TOOK.
YOU DIDN'T TAKE AN OVERALL ON
EVERYTHING.
YOU DID THE MANSLAUGHTER FIRST.
>> WE DID THE MANSLAUGHTER
FIRST.
THAT WAS 100% GUILTY.
>> THE FIRST ONE.
>> BUT THEN AND IT WAS KIND OF
LIKE OH, WOW, HOW DID THAT
HAPPEN?
OKAY, LET'S GO TO THE NEXT ONE.
BUT THERE WERE A COUPLE OF US
WHO PLAYED DEVIL'S ADVOCATE.
AND WE SAID NO, NO, LET'S TALK
ABOUT WHAT THE DEFENSE IS
SAYING, THOUGH, AS THE OPPOSITE
ARGUMENT.
LET'S MAKE SURE WE CAN RULE OUT
THE REASONS WHY IT'S NOT
MANSLAUGHTER FROM THE DEFENSE
SIDE OF THINGS.
>> SO JODI, ACTUALLY, WE GOT A
WHITE BOARD AND SHE STARTED
WRITING UP THE DEFENSE ARGUMENTS
ON THE WHITE BOARD AND WE
DISCUSSED EVERY ONE OF THOSE.
>> WHY WAS IT IMPORTANT FOR YOU
AS DEVIL'S ADVOCATE BECAUSE YOU
WANTED TO MAKE SURE --
>> I ABSOLUTELY WANTED TO MAKE
SURE EVERYONE WAS ON THE SAME
PAGE.
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
WAS COMFORTABLE.
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE WERE
DOING DUE DILIGENCE AND WE
ACTUALLY UNDERSTOOD WHAT OUR
TASK WAS.
THERE WAS NO ROOM FOR ERROR AT
ALL.
>> NO ROOM FOR ERROR.
ALL OF YOU KNEW THE MANSLAUGHTER
YOU FELT THAT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING HE'S GUILTY.
>> WE WENT THROUGH THE EVIDENCE
AND WHEN WE WENT BACK TO THE
DELIBERATION ROOM THE FIRST
THING WE DID WAS TO GO TO THE
EVIDENCE AND THE FACTS.
AND GOING THROUGH THE JURY
INSTRUCTION ABOUT THE
MANSLAUGHTER.
>> HOW MANY TIMES DID YOU VOTE?
>> WE DID A TWICE.
>> THE SECOND CHARGE WAS WHERE
WE SPENT MOST OF OUR TIME.
>> OKAY.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> I THINK WE DID THE SAME
THING.
A VOTE RIGHT AWAY JUST TO DO A
TEMPERATURE CHECK.
AND I BELIEVE IT WAS EITHER FOUR
OR FIVE OF US INITIALLY THAT
SAID NOT GUILTY OR UNDECIDED.
SO THAT ONETH THERE WAS A SPLIT.
I THINK WE WENT THROUGH THREE OR
FOUR DIFFERENT VOTES TOTAL
BEFORE IT GOT TO ALL GUILTY.
AND SO WE SPENT A LONG TIME, AND
THAT'S WHERE WE ACTUALLY -- THIS
WAS -- FOR ME IT WAS THE FIRST
TIME I'D EVER SEEN THE VIDEO WAS
IN THAT COURTROOM, THE WHOLE
THING.
BECAUSE I NEVER -- I COULDN'T
WATCH IT BEFORE THEN.
AND THEN WE HAD TO WATCH IT OVER
AND OVER AND OVER.
>> THE VIDEO.
AND I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE WHAT IT
WAS LIKE FOR SOME OF THE OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM, BUT IT'S
TRAUMATIC, RIGHT?
AND WE ACTUALLY HAD A DISCUSSION
THERE WAS ONE JUROR THAT SAID
LET'S NOT WATCH THE VIDEO -- AND
JUST CAN'T STAND ANYMORE OF IT.
BUT IT'S LIKE, LOOK, WE'VE GOT
TO FIND OUT.
THAT'S WHERE I THINK WE WATCHED
IT MAINLY JUST FOR THE CHECKING
OF THE PULSE, RIGHT?
AND WE'RE LIKE HOW MANY TIMES
DID THEY CHECK FOR A PULSE.
WHAT EXACTLY WERE THE WORDS SAID
FROM ONE OFFICER TO ANOTHER?
AND SO WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
THERE.
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME GOING
THROUGH ALL OF OUR NOTES AND THE
DIFFERENT TESTIMONIES OF PEOPLE.
AND SO THAT ONE TOOK A LONG TIME
TO DISCUSS.
>> SO OUT OF ALL OF IT THERE
WERE HOW MANY NOT GUILTIES?
>> I THINK IT WAS FIVE AT FIRST.
FIVE OUT OF THE 12.
>> AND THEN UNDECIDED?
>> I DON'T REMEMBER.
>> I'M NOT SURE THERE WAS
EVEN -- THERE MAY HAVE BEEN ONE
UNDECIDED AND FOUR NOT GUILTIES.
INITIALLY.
>> WE GOT TO THE POINT ACTUALLY
THAT WE REALIZED FOR CHARGE 2 AT
SOME POINT I THINK IT WAS JODI,
I'M PRETTY SURE IT WAS JODI
SAID, WAIT A MINUTE, DOES THE
INTENDED ACT OF HARM HAVE TO BE
THE DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD, OR
CAN IT BE HIM NOT PRIDING THE
LIFE SUPPORT?
AND IT WAS LIKE ALL OF A SUDDEN
THE LIGHT BULBS JUST WENT ON FOR
THOSE PEOPLE THAT I THINK WERE
UNDECIDED OR ON THE NOT GUILTY
SIDE.
>> GO AHEAD.
I WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU, JODI.
YOU BROUGHT THAT UP.
WHAT DID YOU -- TELL ME WHAT YOU
BROUGHT UP AND WHY.
>> I BROUGHT UP TO THE FACT THAT
THIS IS NOT WHAT HE DID BUT MORE
OR LESS WHAT HE DIDN'T DO.
HE DID NOT PROVIDE LIFESAVING
MEASURES FOR GEORGE FLOYD WHEN
HE KNEW THAT THE GUY WAS IN PAIN
OR NEEDED MEDICAL ATTENTION.
EVEN THE FIREFIGHTER THAT WAS
OPPOSITE SAID CHECK HIS PULSE,
CHECK HIS PULSE.
AND THEY SAID DO YOU WANT TO DO
ANYTHING?
NO, WE'RE LEAVING HIM HERE.
HE HAD AMPLE TO ROLL HIM OVER
AND START CPR AND HE DIDN'T.
HE DIDN'T MOVE ONE BIT.
AND EVEN WHEN THE EMS CAME AND
CHECKED HIM, HE NEVER EVEN GOT
UP.
AND HE KNEW HE'D BEEN LIFELESS
FOR 30 SECONDS TO A MINUTE.
HE STILL NEVER STEPPED UP AND
LET THE EMS COME IN AND DO THEIR
JOB.
HE HAD TO HAVE THE EMS TAP HIM
TO GET UP.
THAT TO ME SAID MORE THAN WHAT
HE ACTUALLY DID, THAT HE JUST
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING TO HELP HIM
AT THAT TIME.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THAT WAS THE
LIGHT BULB?
>> WELL, WHEN WE WERE IN
DELIBERATIONS AND JODI DID BRING
THAT UP AND WE DID LOOK THROUGH
EVERYTHING VERY, VERY CAREFULLY
WHAT I THOUGHT ABOUT WAS
SOMETHING SAID DURING THE TRIAL.
AND THAT IS THE MINNEAPOLIS
POLICE DEPARTMENT HAS A MODEL.
AND IF I UNDERSTAND IT CORRECTLY
THEIR MOTTO AND IN OUR CUSTODY,
IN OUR CARE.
GEORGE FLOYD WAS IN THEIR
CUSTODY.
HE WAS NEVER IN THEIR CARE.
AND THAT FOR ME IT JUST -- IT
JUST HIT HARD.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY EVER
CARED FOR HIM.
>> THERE WAS A POINT WHERE THE
PROSECUTORS POINTED OUT WHEN THE
LIFE LEFT HIS BODY ON THAT
VIDEO.
WHAT WAS THAT MOMENT LIKE?
>> I HAD A BIG GASP.
I'VE JUST -- I'VE NEVER
EXPERIENCED ANYTHING LIKE THAT
BEFORE.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US HAVE.
IT WAS VERY, VERY TRAUMATIC.
AND IT JUST -- JUST HURT.
JUST HURT MY WHOLE SOUL, MY
WHOLE BODY.
I FELT PAIN FOR HIS FAMILY.
IT WAS VERY -- IT WAS VERY HARD.
THE WHOLE EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN
HARD.
>> WHEN YOU SEE THE VIDEO THE
GUY DIED LIKE THREE MINUTES, 29
AND I'M THINKING THEY POINTED
OUT WHEN THE LIFE LEFT THE BODY.
>> YES, YOU CAN SEE HIS EYES,
HE'S CONSCIOUS, AND THEN YOU SEE
THAT HE ISN'T.
THAT'S THE MOMENT THE LIFE GOES
OUT OF HIS BODY.
>> GO THROUGH THE WHOLE EVIDENCE
HE WAS -- WE SEE ALL THAT